cette invention pierre door pour le
groupe l'est républicain merci madame la
présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la santé de la
solidarité des droits des femmes vous
réjouir madame de la diminution des
déficits sociaux c'est aller un peu vite
car vous manipuler les chiffres pour
masquer l'énorme décalage entre vos
promesses et la réalité budgétaire
je vous rappelle - set et demi milliard
en 2015 loin dé 5,9 milliards de 2012
des promesses non tenues et nous sommes
malheureusement pour la france coutumier
du fait avec votre majorité le retour à
l'équilibré des comptes proclamer haut
et fort pour 2017 ne se fera pas avant
2020 et on constate dans ce plfss à
venir une dérive des dépenses une
absence de réformes structurelles
un renoncement à vos engagements formels
depuis trois ans vous êtes à des années
lumières des conseils répétés de la cour
des comptes
la france est malade vous aggravé son
mal en malmenant cette fois encore
l'industrie pharmaceutique
les pharmaciens les cliniques privées
une officine ferme tous les deux jours
dans notre pays
le désert s'installe sous votre
influence des sites industriels
pharmaceutiques ferme comme celui de
corrèze pourtant chère à l'elysée et
vous exacerbée en plus la colère des
professionnels de santé se réjouir par
contre de l' équilibre obtenu dans la
branche vieillesse oui bien entendu
mais reconnaissons que la loi fillon de
2011 en est l'instigatrice
avec le report de 60 à 62 ans vous
démontrez année après année malgré des
beaux discours votre incapacité à
apporter les bons remèdes et vous
envoyer les solutions à vos successeurs
ma question sera simple quand
prendrez-vous enfin les bonnes décisions
merci merci monsieur lors la parole est
à mme allain 2010 affaires sociales de
la santé et les droits des femmes à une
tourelle de la paroisse si madame
la présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député jean-pierre
door
je vous connais depuis si longtemps que
je m'interroge sur la raison pour
laquelle vous êtes vous aujourd'hui à
des années lumières de la lucidité de la
perspicacité sur ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
parce que monsieur d'or les choses sont
assez simples au fond demandons nous ce
qui vaut mieux vaut-il mieux un
gouvernement qui multiplie par deux en
cinq ans le déficit de la sécurité
sociale et dans le même temps réduit
augmente ce qui reste à la charge des
français pour leur santé est interdit le
financement des retraites ce
gouvernement c'était le vote
nous de notre côté en l'espace de trois
ans nous avons diminué par plus de 40 %
le déficit de la sécurité sociale
je comprends que cela vous gêne et je
comprends d'autant plus que cela vous
gêne quand vous savez quand vous
apprenez que cette réduction du déficit
elle s'est fait dans le même temps avec
la diminution de ce qui reste à la
charge des français en matière de santé
quand la réduction du déficit
elle s'est faite avec la mise en place
de la pénibilité pour les retraites de
nos concitoyens les plus fragiles et
quand vous savez que nous avons amélioré
l'accès au droit alors le projet de loi
que nous présentons monsieur le député
c'est un projet qui poursuit la
réduction des déficits et qui améliore
les droits avec la mise en place d'une
garantie pour les impayés de pension
alimentaire pour les femmes qui restent
seules avec des enfants à charge
avec la mise en place d'une
complémentaire santé pour les personnes
retraitées fragile avec la mise en place
d'une protection universelle maladie
avec la prise en charge du dépistage de
toutes les femmes pour le cancer du sein
avec la liste en charge d'un parcours de
prise en charge pour l'obésité
vous le voyez monsieur le député nous
allions responsabilité financière et
justice sociale
ce que vous n'avez pas su faire merci
madame la parole est à monsieur
christian prendre